hey guys it's Justine and in this video
today we are talking about iOS 17. now
Apple announced the newest iPhone
software at WWDC and ever since then I
could not wait to show it to you I had
been testing it out and they just
officially released the public beta
there are a ton of new features to talk
about so we're going to be getting into
all of that and all the new features and
at the end of the video I'm going to
reveal one of the features that I am
most excited about so stick around for
that and if you want maybe you could hit
the like button or subscribe if you're
not already because I've got another
video dropping very soon about Mac OS
Sonoma so let's get into it and I will
show you some of my favorite new stuff
in iOS 17. phone FaceTime messages are
all getting really big updates there's
improvements to airdrop with a new
feature called name drop I see what you
did there the keyboard is also getting a
nice refresh with more intelligent text
input and dictation there's a new
standby mode which takes some
inspiration from nightstand mode on the
Apple watch a new native app called
Journal plus added tools for vision and
mental health inside of the health app a
big theme with all of these new features
seems to be a focus on machine learning
which makes a lot of sense considering
how much is happening with AI right now
and it looks like Apple's heading
towards utilizing this kind of tech a
lot more in their software in the future
I also think it's interesting how Apple
doesn't actually like to use the word or
letters AI or even mention artificial
intelligence it seems like for most
consumers that can kind of sound like a
scary thing so Apple has done a really
great job of finding their way around it
to make it seem just like magic the
first thing that I want to start with is
the phone app now on my actual phone I
don't like to admit it but I've kind of
moved the phone app like off of the main
page because I don't actually like
making phone calls but it is kind of
exciting to see it getting a little bit
of an update and this is all kind of
starting with the new contact posters
feature now you can make this huge full
screen contact page with custom
backgrounds text and images or you can
even use a memoji so now when someone
calls you or you call someone this card
will pop up on their phone so let's make
our first one and I'll show you guys how
it works so here's one of the contacts
that I made already it's super easy to
add an update so I'm going to edit this
you can add multiple ones so like this
one is super basic and you can actually
set these to be given to like different
people too which is kind of cool so I'm
gonna do a memoji one let's do a little
piggy because I
because I like pigs
oh I can make it do my own little
expression here
okay that's fitting you can change the
fonts you can change the size
okay what do you guys think do we love
it or do we love it I feel like if this
got sent to some of my friends phones
they actually wouldn't be surprised at
all so you guys can see that I still
have my pandemic Emoji in here and
let's go with my new updated one and
she's got her little hoodie on I kind of
like that fun actually clearly we're
having a little purple theme okay
there it is
and done of course you can add all of
your contact info in there as well but
for the sake of this video We're not
gonna do it another
phone app that I'm
excited about is live voicemail I mean
this is so freaking cool so before you
could get a translation of the voicemail
after someone leaves it but with this
you'll be able to see a live speech to
text translation as the person is
leaving the voicemail this is super cool
because if it is something really
important you'll be able to see right
away that maybe you should pick it up
and not sit there and read the text
instead which I think we're all going to
be very guilty of messages are getting a
couple very cool updates too so now you
can use search filters inside of the app
and now voice messages automatically get
transcribed which I am so glad that this
is finally a thing because there's
something that I love and hate about
voice messages I think they're great
because they're super personal but I
always forget what people say and now
it'll transcribe it and I can just kind
of look at it really quick love that
another new feature in messages is
check-in so with this you can let
friends and family know when you've
arrived somewhere this is great for my
family because we're always asking each
other like where are you at are you
going to be here and of course you can't
really lie and say uh I just left I'm
just I'm just leaving now oh yeah yeah I
already left when in reality you're
running around your house trying to find
your keys your purse your shoes your
phone your extra phone and your extra
extra phone because because that's just
the person that you are so you can
choose the data that you'd like to share
if you don't arrive you can do a limited
option so this includes your current
location and details about the battery
Network signal or you can do full this
includes basically all of the data and
it'll give you the location of the last
iPhone unlock in Apple watch removal so
let's do that because I feel like if I'm
using this and something happens I would
definitely want them to know we're going
to send a check in to my sister okay
we're not because she doesn't have
um she doesn't have IOS 17 installed so
we're going to send it to Tyler Apple
Store Cupertino so it's going to take me
5 hours 45 minutes I'm probably gonna
walk so it's gonna take me 152 hours so
I'm going to share that with Tyler
it's going to take the 152 hours to walk
there we'll check in
when I get there okay this is great I
also have the option to share my name
and photo with him which I guess yeah
let's do it I'm probably gonna change
that photo but for now
um that's what we're gonna get and of
course one of the other things that I'm
so hyped about is the new stickers
feature uh let's make a freaking sticker
I've already made a few but I'm going to
show you guys how easy it is so here we
go we go into the stickers and these are
the ones that I've already made and with
these I've basically just used live
photos Okay so I'm gonna start making my
action now
[Music]
so we're gonna add a sticker so here's
the one that I just did you just hit
add sticker and that's like that's it so
I'm just gonna put it over top of
it
it's pretty cool I'm really excited
about this I'm gonna be making a whole
entire like a little sticker pack that I
can send to people and it's so easy like
literally anyone can do this in seconds
I mean you saw it happen right before
your eyes next up is standby so when you
turn your phone sideways while it's
charging there's an all new full screen
display setup now this seems to be
inspired by the nightstand mode for the
Apple watch which I absolutely love and
this just makes so much sense so when
your phone is in standby you can
customize the screen with different
clock Styles photos widgets and smart
Stacks I am really into this and I think
this might be the first step towards
some kind of apple smart home product I
don't know like maybe like a digital
homepod or we can just keep using
standby mode with our iPhone because
that also is pretty much the same thing
okay we've got our little stand
now let's test out standby mode here we
go so here's a few of the
stasic ones Apple already has like
pre-made in here so we're gonna open up
this we're gonna add some more things
let's add
um we'll add some reminders add widgets
okay we love that so I can just swipe
through these
we've got the podcast
reminders no events today oh my goodness
Maddie you're so cute let's go with
nature
so standby mode pretty awesome very very
excited about it now widgets have also
been revamped in iOS 17 so instead of
only being able to tap a widget to open
the app you can now perform actions
right on the widget itself without
leaving your home screen I like this
because it actually makes widgets seem
more useful like I like being able to
visually see these things but now being
able to actually interact with it it
just makes so much more sense now
airdrop is probably one of my favorite
features in the iOS Apple ecosystem and
they have a new feature called name drop
so basically it's a super easy way to
connect with new people so instead of
exchanging numbers or typing in insta
handles or whatever you guys do today I
don't know snap I'm not sure maybe I
don't want to know now all you have to
do is bring your two phones together and
these big beautiful contact posters will
pop up and you can instantly exchange
info from device device something that I
thought would be also interesting if
somebody comes up to you and like they
try to get your number and like you
don't really want to share and you're
not realize on or maybe like you just
want to give them your email address not
your phone number you can choose which
contact poster or to send them so I like
that a lot now another thing that I'm
pretty stoked about is Apple's new
journal app now we don't have this just
yet to try because it's not actually
coming out until later this year but I'm
really interested in this I don't know
about you guys but I've definitely tried
to use journaling apps in the past but I
wasn't really able to stick with it but
this is really cool because it actually
uses machine learning to give Smart
Suggestions for your journal entries
including photos you took or places you
went workouts you did that day and it
even gives you writing prompts to get
you started and I feel like this is a
really smart way to make it easier to
actually
journaling all right so moving on there
are some really nice updates to the
keyboard experience too with improved
accuracy while typing so you can still
see these still pop up but there's like
a little line that kind of is underlined
so with that you can go back and change
it if that's not what you wanted to say
so let's see if I write duck okay well
that I don't I don't want to test it out
do I test it out I don't know let me
just see I'm just gonna test it out I'm
gonna test it out Tyler just below the
text just blur it okay so they won't
know I'm actually writing it oh my God
it actually wrote it it didn't correct
it
oh geez okay wait
um I need to delete that I'm gonna
delete it
undo send undo send
okay everyone sent the message we've
also got some new changes to airplay now
as well so your phone is gonna start to
learn how you use airplay which devices
you use the most and how you use them
there's a new AirPlay devices list and
it will now suggest the most relevant
device and eventually as it continues to
learn your AirPlay habits it will begin
automatically connecting to your devices
so for me I always listen to music on my
homepod in the bathroom while I'm
getting ready for the day so my phone
will learn that and just automatically
connect so I won't have to do anything
it just knows so the health and fitness
apps are both getting some really cool
upgrades now I'm pretty hyped about this
because in the health app there are some
new insights into vision and mental
health the new State of Mind feature
lets you track how you're feeling day to
day with this interactive screen and
this is great because reflecting on how
you feel is very important and I love
that they are adding this type of
feature this is cool because this
actually is giving you a bunch of
resources to care for your mental health
learn about your mental health common
concerns definitely feel like this is a
really cool addition to the health app
now for vision the Health app can now
track your time in daylight and it can
help manage your screen distance if
you're holding your phone too close to
your face I am excited about this
because I do have a three-year-old niece
who's three going on 20 watching her
watch YouTube videos I kept getting so
upset because she was using the phone
and her iPad and holding it so close to
her face and I kept telling her to move
it back so with this the app is actually
not going to let you view your content
unless you move it to a safe distance so
now if she actually wants to watch this
content she's gonna have to listen to it
and move it further back in the fitness
app the sharing feed has been improved
to make it easier to navigate and see
your friend's progress there's also new
weekly tips from Apple fitness trainers
and an all new design for the trophy
case so you can see all of your Awards
challenges and competitions all in one
place there's also a new
which lets you create a workout schedule
based on your specific goals you select
which days and which workouts and
Fitness Plus provides a custom plan and
gives you reminders to keep you on track
6 minutes Monday Wednesday Friday build
land core
kickboxing
Pilates tread strength oh this gives you
oh I like this look how cool so if you
have 60 minutes it's going to give you
all the things that you can do oh my
gosh I love this okay create my plan
this is so cool there are some other
cool changes coming like offline maps
and EV charge locations inside the maps
app you can also now drop the hey part
when you're saying hey
if you prefer Spotlight search is
getting a little bit smarter as well as
visual lookup and live text the
reminders app now automatically sorts
your grocery list by category which I'm
so hyped about that facial recognition
in photos now can recognize animals as
it very well should now with all of
these new awesome features there is
still one thing that I am so so so so so
excited about and that's the update to
airpods now if you watch my videos then
you know that I am absolutely obsessed
with my Gen 2 airpods and I basically I
really I never shut up about them they
are getting even better which I didn't
even think was possible so you can now
just tap the airpod stem to mute and
unmute when on a call they also have
improved automatic device switching
which was already really good so that's
amazing that it's gonna connect even
faster there's also personalized volume
now so using machine learning the
airpods will know your volume
preferences between media types but the
coolest airpods feature is the brand new
adaptive audio setting this is basically
a mix between active noise cancellation
and transparency mode that seamlessly
Blends your audio into the environment
around you and the reason that I'm so
excited about this is I go running a lot
and these airpods have been my best
running friend but sometimes the noise
cancellation is so intense that I can't
hear anything around me at all which is
actually not very safe so it's really
good to know that if a car is coming or
if something is happening around me or
if there's a bike that's trying to say
hey scoot over but sometimes the
transparency mode can kind of take you
out of that Groove because I still want
to hear my music and get into the zone
so this is like a perfect combination of
the two so I'm very excited to test this
out so my friends those are some of my
favorite features I would love to hear
from you what are your favorites in the
comments below I'll see you guys in the
next one bye